foreign
YouTube channel today we will dwell into
statistics and uncover the 10 most
essential Concepts every data scientist
should know
statistics from the backbone of data
science allowing us to extract valuable
insights and make informed decisions
from raw data now in this video we will
explore various fundamental statistical
Concepts essential for any aspiring data
scientist we will start with descriptive
statistics which helps us understand the
essential characteristics of data set
from there we'll move on to inferential
statistics enabling us to make
predictions and draw conclusions about
larger populations based on a sample
data
probability a Cornerstone of Statistics
will be our next stop we will uncover
how it quantifies uncertainty and place
a crucial role in data analysis we'll
also cover sampling techniques
regressional analysis and hypothesis
testing which are indispensable tools
for understanding relationships make
inferences and validating hypothesis
furthermore we'll dive into statistical
distributions which provide a framework
for understanding data patterns and
behavior statistical inference and
experimental design will be explored
emphasizing the importance of drawing
meaningful conclusions and ensuring
reliable results
finally we will touch upon time series
analysis a vital skill for analyzing and
forecasting data collected over time by
end of this tutorial you'll have a solid
foundation in these 10 key statistic
Concepts empowering you to call Friendly
embark on your data science Journey so
let's dive in and unlock the power of
Statistics in data science but before we
get started if these are the types of
videos you'd like to watch then you know
how YouTube algorithm Works let's do the
drill get subscribed to our YouTube
channel like our videos and hit the Bell
icon to never miss an update from Simply
learn if you are one of the aspiring
data scientists looking for online
training graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with data
science by learning from the experts
then try giving a shot to Caltech
postgraduate program in data science
from Simply learn in collaboration with
IBM the link in the description box
would navigate to the home page where
you can find a complete overview of the
program being offered let's begin with
discussing the top 10 most important
statistics concepts for data science or
to our training experts hello all let's
get started with the top 10 most
important statistics concepts for data
science first on the list is descriptive
statistics
descriptive statistics involves
summarizing and describing the main
features of a data set it includes
measuring such as mean median mode
standard deviation and range which
provide insights into the data's central
tendency spread and distribution now
proceeding ahead we have inferential
statistics inferential statistics help
draw conclusions and predict a
population based on a sample it involves
hypothesis testing confidence intervals
and P values allowing data scientists to
make informations and statements about
the population from which the sample is
drawn next on the docket is probability
probability is the foundation of
Statistics it measures the likelihood of
an event occurring and enables data
scientists to qualify uncertainty
understanding probability is crucial for
tasks such as estimating probabilities
calculating expected values and
conducting Bayesian analysis the fourth
one on the list is sampling techniques
sampling techniques are essential for
collecting representative data from a
population
simple random sampling satisfied
sampling cluster sampling and systematic
sampling are standard techniques used to
ensure that the sample accurately
reflects the characteristics of
population
the fifth one on the docket is
regression analysis
filtration analysis is used to model and
analyze the relationship between
variables simple linear multiple and
logistic regression are commonly used
techniques to understand how one or more
variables influence an outcome or
dependent variable proceeding ahead we
have hypothesis testing hypothesis
testing is used to evaluate the validity
of a claim or hypothesis about a
population based on Sample data it
involves settling up a null and
alternative hypothesis calculating test
statistics and make decisions based on
p-values and significance levels with
that we can move on to the next one that
is statistical distributions
statisticals distributions describe data
patterns and behavior understanding
distributions such as the normal
binomial and poisson distribution is
crucial for analyzing and modeling
various data types now we have the
statistical inference in the eighth
place statistical inference involves a
drawing conclusions and making
predictions based on Sample data it
includes Concepts such as confident
intervals margin of error and sample
size determination which help quantify
the Precision and reliability of
estimates and predictions the proceeding
to the ninth one we have experimental
design experimental design refers to the
planning and structure of experiments to
ensure valid and reliable results
Concepts such as randomization control
groups and replication are used to
minimize bias and co-founding variables
allow a data scientists to make casual
inferences finally they have the most
important one on the templates time
series analysis time series analysis
analyzes and predicts data points
collected over time it involves
techniques such as Trend analysis
seasonality and auto regressive
integrated move and auto regressive
integrated moving average or
arima models which are useful for
forecasting and understanding temporal
patterns in data these 10 statistics
Concepts will provide a solid foundation
for data scientists to explore analyze
and draw meaningful insights from data
with this we have come to an end of this
session on top 10 most important
statistics concepts for data science
should you have any questions on any of
the topics discussed in this tutorial do
let us know in the comment section below
where our team of experts will be more
than happy to answer them as soon as
possible until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning to get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign